- Merci beaucoup. On vous
retrouve à Zone économie.
On va retrouver Josselin Coulon,
bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
- Vous êtes en France
aujourd'hui. Vous avez ce pott
de vue de France avec tous les
événements. Cela bouge
énormément. Parlons de qui lève
avec eux ces hommes qui se sont
très peu d'expérience qu'ils ont
P de l'armée. C'est une ville de
3 millions d'habitants?
On se demande combien de temps
vont-ils pouvoir donner?
- Je trouve qu'on est dans une
situation que l'on a vécue en
2003 lors de l'invasion de
l'Irak par les États-Unis.
Qu'est-ce que les États-Unis ont
dit au gouvernement irakien?
Rendez-vous ou bien en vous
écrase. C'est exactement ce qui
est arrivé. Les États-Unis on
illégalement envahi l'Irtttt
tué des centaines de milliers de
personnes. En plonger la région
dans un bain de sang et n'ont
jamais été sanctionné pour
s'exprimer. Aujourd'hui, en
Ukraine, on risque de revivre
cela parce que ce n'est pas vrai
que de distribuer 18 000 fusils
à 4 millions d'habitants, cela
va empêcher les troupes russes
d'envahir et d'occuper qui avait
et les autres grandes villes. Il
faut trouver une solution pour
éviter ce bain de sang.
- Parlons des solutions. Parlons
de l'OTAN. Il a eu rencontre
encore, un peu de presse par la
suite. L'OTAN ne s'engage pas
dans la conflit. Elle essaie de
sécuriser les pays qui entourent
l'Ukraine. Mais l'auteur n'a
jamais eu l'intention vraiment
de s'impliquer et d'aller porter
secours à l'Ukraine?
- Nous avons dit et quand je
nous ce sont les pays
occidentaux depuis le début de
cette crise qu'on peut faire
remonter à 2014. Disons depuis
le début décembre, lorsque
Poutine a envoyé ses lettres au
gouvernement occidentaux que
jamais on utiliserait la force
pour défendre l'Ukraine. Parce
que l'Ukraine n'est pas membre
de l'OTAN. Mais en plus, on
n'avait pas de conflit avec la
Russie puisque cela pourrait
dégénérer vers un conflit
nu p p p p p p partir du momenùu
vous envoyez le signale à la
Russie que vous n'allez pas
défendre l'Ukraine vous ouvrez
1, Boulevard pour les Russes
pour leur permettre de rentrer
en Ukraine et de faire ce qu'ils
veulent. Alors que l'OTAN peut
bien faire toutes les
déclarations qu'elle veut, elle
peut envoyer le nombre de
soldats qu'elle veut dans les
pays membres de l'OTAN, cela ne
changera rien à la situation. Je
pense que la façon d'ouvrir une
négociation ou les dialogues,
c'est pour les ukrainiens qui
sont tout seuls, et accepter
certaines des conditions de
Vladimir poutine. Cela nous
éviterait un l l l l l l l l'Ir.
- Les ukrainiens ressortissants
qui viveouououououououous
écoutez ce soir. Ils doivent
être que ça n'a pas de bon sens.
b b b b b b b baisser les bras.
- C'est un abaissement les bras,
qui va venir la défendre et
comment vont-ils se défendre
contre une force 10 fois
supérieure à la référence? Les
ukrainiens sont très mal armés.
Elles ne sont pas très bien
entraînées puisque nous avions
des missions militaires pour
entraîner l'armée ukrainienne.
Ils sont face à un géant au même
titre que l'Iraq était
passagère. S'il n'ava
écrasé, il faut éviter le pire
et éviter le bain de sang. La
seule façon de le faire,
malheureusement, cela s'asseoir
avec l'espoir pour essayer de
tirer le meilleur compromis
possible. C'est terrible à dire
mais c'est ainsi.
- Il y a eu cette possibilité de
néé é é é é é é é é é évoquée
par Monsieur Boutonnet lui-même.
Il a dit que je pourrais
déléguer une équipe, donc on est
en Biélorussie. Et on
négocierait. Mais on négocierai?
- C'est une bonne question.
Puisque on a l'impression que
poutine veut se débarrasser de
gouvernement actuel. Il s'agit
de voir dans les prochaines
heures et jours si cela est
vraiment le cas. Peut-ê
pourrait y avoir une dégaine
action du président Zelensky qui
sera à Minsk p
il faut négocier sur quelque
chose. Poutine a déjà posé deux
conditions mardi de cette
semaine : il a dit que l'Ukraine
doit renoncer formellement à
demander son adhésion à l'OTAN
et deuxièmement, les graines
doit proclamer un statut de
neutralité comme la Finlande ou
l'Autriche. Ce sont les deux
conditions essentielles, en tout
cas, selon poutine et si on peut
la croire pour mettre fin au L e
bien entendue qui est compris
dans la lettre que poutine avovx
concernant par exemple une
nouvelle discussion sur une
architecture de sécurité
européenne où tous les pays
européens se répartit.
- J'aimerais qu'on parle du
Canada. Comment trouver la
position du Canada? Monsieur
Trudeau parle de sanction
supplémentaire. Il veut retirer
la Russie de Swift. Il y avait
ctctctctctctctctctctctctct pours
pays européens qui dépendent de
l'énergie qui provient de la
Russie.
- Les pays occidentaux ne font
pas grand-chose parce qu'ils ne
peuvent pas faire grand-chose.
Il faut bien comprendre que les
sanctions qui ont été adoptées
n'auront pas assez loin. Il
faudrait vraiment frapper le
secteur énergétique, mais
vous frappez le secteur
énergétique russe, vous frappez
plusieurs pays européens qui
dépendent à 100 % de leur
approvisionnement énergétique.
Je pense en particulier aux pays
baltes ou à l'Autriche. C'est
pour cela qu'i
division au sein des occidentaux
au sujet de l'ampleur des
sanctions.
- On a l'impression qu'il y a
beaucoup de pays qui sont pris
en otage par la Russie.
- On est dans une économie
mondialisée. Ce n'est plus'i'i'e
dizaine d'années qui est isolé
mais qui avait très peu de
rapport avec le reste du monde.
Aujourd'hui, la Russie estananae
mondiale. Je regardais
aujourd'hui les réactions de la
Chine, de l'Inde, du Brésil et
de bien entrepris qui ne
condamnent pas l'agression.
Il demande cessez-le-feu, mavoue
force sont très différents
aujourd'hui qu'il y
L'Occident n'est plus en mesure
de dicter les conditions de
l'ordre mondia